joining us now to talk about it is the
man who's a podcast gm shuffle and v sin
and so much more that he's up to right
now back here on the rich eisen show how
are you michael lombardi
i'm doing great rich thank you thanks
for having me i appreciate it so
what what is going on in jacksonville
best you can tell well i think you know
i think this is probably a lot more to
do about money than it is about how long
urban's going to continue coaching the
jacksonville jaguars i think you could
see by the press release
that there is some discontent with his
behavior i think the bigger issue
frankly is his credibility and his trust
with his players i mean
when i've been in the league 35 years
i've been on all sorts of airplanes
flying home after tough losses
i've never been on a plane where the
head coach wasn't on it
i've never been on one
i mean you know whether you had a bye
week whether it was the end of the
season whether it was something else i
mean everybody flies you go down as a
team you act as a team i think that was
the first step you know what happened
over the weekend is between him and his
wife he has to work through those issues
but to me
i think the lack of trust when you tell
your team we're all in this together and
then you decide to take a three-day
vacation to stay back in cincinnati
we're really not all in this together
and i think that started the sparks and
there's some discontent going on within
the building and these meetings that
have been happening the last two days
are more about
how is this going to end then how is
this going to get repaired
i mean
you can ask the two guys here brockman
and um and deltoofer you're on that text
range as well tj jefferson we were all
my guys here as soon as this was
trending we started texting each other
and sending each other's videos like can
you believe this can you believe that
you guys can confirm the first thing i
said to you is like does that mean he
wasn't on the team playing going home is
it like did an owen floor head coach not
get on the team plane to go home do we
know that for sure like did he not go
home with the guys in the flight i did
not go home on the team playing that's a
fact and and and you gotta really wonder
you know and i don't blame this on trent
balcke his general manager but if i
would have been the general manager of
the team i would have said urban look
we're not at ohio state like the head
coach flies home on every plane like we
don't have a recruiting plane
and it sends a horrible message to the
team
if you're not on the plane because
what's going to happen next week when we
play
somewhere else and half the players want
to stay in atlanta
and you know they're not coming back
with us because you just did it
like this is a horrible precedent
you know
usually every team has a rule whoever
goes on the trip comes back on the trip
now if there's something going on in the
town and there's certain exceptions i
get that we all get that you know a
family member all those things but that
to me was yeah he wasn't on the plane
and i would have said to him urban look
you're making a lot of money fly back
with us spend the night in jacksonville
get a private plane and fly you back to
cincinnati
what
what's it going to cost you
you lost your credibility that's worth
that's priceless
i i i'm kind of speechless
i i gotta be honest with you
mike uh
and are you
you know i shouldn't say sure but i mean
you you you've been there done that i
mean the language you see out of the the
the press release i said you know before
there's two ways to look at a glass half
full of an owner saying you know what
man like i i went and i got the guy like
i went ahead and got the guy the number
one college coach one of the most
winningest college coaches outside of uh
nick saban obviously who's never gonna
come back to the nfl but i got the guy
and not only did i get the guy i'm
hooking him up with one of the most
generationally talented quarterbacks
that's ever come out of college i got
this and and and this is like a glass
half full like let's see if we can put
humpty dumpty back together again and
the other way i looked at it was like
you know the other glass is half full of
lawyers
and you know so you're saying like you
read this press release as to mean like
we're we're working on terms of
of firing to make sure that to tell him
like you've already violated the morals
clause you're lucky or not gone now like
you really think that they've reached
that point in jacksonville through this
one video i mean i i think it's it's
been brewing
i think it hasn't been an easy ride
you know starting with remember the
strength coach that he hired that they
haven't let go i mean this hasn't been a
smooth smooth tenure down in
jacksonville the whole signing of tim
tebow the most ridiculous signing in all
of sports to convert him to a tight end
at 32.
i mean that just shows you that what
what were we going to do with tim tebow
he's 32 years old he's going to be if
he's the best he could be is the third
string tight end that means he's got to
play in the kicking game that means he's
going to be a great special teams player
there's i mean we're going to pay him a
million dollars for that like why would
we do that that those jobs are for the
rookies
they made no sense
everything he's done has made no sense
and i think that
more than what what i see as an outsider
looking in
the people in the building
see it and the people in the building
that have gone to the meetings that
listen to him that there's no
trust in what he's doing i mean it's you
know look
coaching in college and coaching in the
pros are two entirely different things
two entirely different things you've got
to be a strategist in the pro football
there's no easy game on the schedule you
can play the houston texas tomorrow and
he was favorite of that game and got
whooped
so i just think this is probably wrong
place wrong time for his career so what
would you if you you had the ability
either through this show or to get to
connect with shad khan what would you
counsel him in your years of being in
the professional
ranks michael lombardi
i would say this i would say the most
important thing
is understanding when you get it right
and when you get it wrong
and you can't fall into the sunk cost
fallacy
that like we're better off moving away
from this now early
than we are staying on with it and
hurting our team
and i think he's going to have to make
that decision because the players
this isn't about me
the players do they believe the coach
can he win the players trust back
michael silver has a report out today
that the players are laughing at it
and if that's true and i don't doubt
michael silver if that's true
then then this problem is just going to
intensify
and it's going to come down to so for me
this is more about money than it is
about is he going to continue to coach
you know let's just let's play this out
say he continues to coach for the next
three four or five weeks and he keeps
losing how do you think this is going to
get better
yeah i mean i don't know if you saw the
tweet from uh chris long who i love and
have nothing but the utmost of respect
for
and comes from an incredible uh nfl
family lineage obviously
his tweet was uh if i'm a veteran player
in jacksonville i'm now my own boss
that's what he tweeted
what do you think he means by that what
do you think you mean what what do you
think that means put it in terms of well
it means that there's that he can do the
rules don't apply to anybody
when he when he didn't fly back on that
plane
he basically he was telling everybody
there's four areas of leadership right
there's the management of attention
means you have a plan there's management
of meeting means you can explain your
plan there's management of self which
means you govern yourself as the leader
and the most important is called
management of trust the players trust
you you could be a jerk as a coach you
could be a jerk but if you're a
consistent jerk they'll listen to you
that's been proven over time
consistency is the most important
quality a coach has to have
and when you lose the trust of the team
management of trust you've lost the team
michael lombardi the gm shuffle podcast
co-host uh and also um the daily coach
newsletter is how you can get so much
more with him and of course musberger's
vsan uh every single day right here on
the rich eisen show um how do you view
the news out of pittsburgh that um ben
has hip issues
and uh tomlin says he's absolutely still
the best quarterback for the job in
pittsburgh how do you see what's going
on in western pa right now rich i think
that's true i think that mason rudolph
isn't ready to be the starting
quarterback
i think that ben is still the best
player and i think that just tells you
that pittsburgh doesn't have a
quarterback i said this off-season i
thought that they made a mistake
bringing them back because here's what i
do know
when older players don't look good in
september they never look good in
november or december
and i think ben behind a bad line and
it's a bad line in fairness to big ben
it's a bad lie but he can't move
and because he can't move it's
problematic for him
and you have to be thinking what he's
got to be thinking do you think he
thinks he made him a bad decision coming
back or or what like what what's the
solve here what's the fix you know rich
of all my years in the league anytime a
player voluntarily takes a pay cut i
would have been suspicious
why is that
because they typically never want to
take a pay cut they probably won't
they're coming back because they
probably know
this is their last chance to come back
which roster would you take right now in
the nfl if you could only have one whose
roster would you take
mike
if i only had a one roster one roster
one roster that you would take right now
in the nfl i i think i would take the
the los angeles chargers really okay not
bills not chiefs
not bucks well i mean look i got a
really young team i got two great
receivers i got a really good pass
rusher defensively i think they had a
really good team
okay last one for you michael lombardi
what do you think brady and belichick
talked about behind that wall for 24
minutes sunday night i think they talked
about how much the media made something
out of nothing
because i think that's what it was i was
around both guys for a long time most of
my career and i've never seen either one
of them have a problem they've always
handled it they've always been very
respectful to one another they've always
been willing to have hard conversations
so i i think it was probably about the
six trophies that they won together and
how nobody can take that away from them
yeah but i mean what what why would that
take 24 minutes why would they need a
situation to talk about that i mean
a lot of this stuff has to come from
somewhere you know what i'm saying
i i don't know i mean probably they
haven't caught up in a while i don't
know how long 24 minutes takes to have a
conversation
but i i know this that there's there was
never any bad blood between the two of
them that i know
okay last one for you crystal ball it
for me i know that's one of the cliches
michael lombardi in the nfl is i don't
have a crystal ball
what what crystal ball what happens in
jacksonville for me what do you think i
think either he if he makes it through
the year he won't be there next year and
i would be more than surprised if he
does make it through the year well i
mean he'll be looking for i think
they'll be looking for an offensive
coach to coach the generational talent
that you mentioned okay at the end of
the year but wouldn't the wouldn't urban
knowing that there's an off ramp and
knowing what a disaster this would mean
for his uh you know reputation legacy
anything like that that you know um that
that the usc off-ramp would be something
he'd want to get on lickety-split don't
you think if fc wants them i mean if fc
wants them i think that's got to be yeah
i think it becomes more in play but we
all think sc wants them do we know sc
wants them for sure
i don't know that
michael lombardi i appreciate it uh what
time is your show
on v sin every day
okay so how do most burger for me will
you
thank you rich appreciate you that's it
that's michael lombardi right here on
the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here